hello there reject nation I'm Greg album
hello I'm John I know it's the first
time I've ever attempted that yeah we're
gonna watch from how it should have
ended how it chapter two should have
ended controversial ending or more than
this satisfying ending to the tizzy
let's check it out man they're great
they're one of the best channels in the
world all friends call you that's a mean
thing to say
[Music]
[Music]
yes it is back yeah Stanley look at your
wife now back to me so why not instead
of killing yourself come back to Derry
and help fight Pennywise so she won't
have to be sad Stanley look down back up
we're bombing you we're all back
together as it will be house of
Pennywise sousou's club what's you know
hand back at me I have it it's all the
tokens of those memories you had look
again the tokens have now vanished they
weren't important they say two pointless
jobs their hours of your life now we
find this clown before and one by not
being scared so we can easily finish
them off now that we're frickin adults
also anything is a weapon if you believe
this in theory right yeah let's kill
this in clam anyway
this rock
[Music]
Richie you got a real gun yeah sorry
Daria's a messed up place I don't feel
safe here
oh well that was super easy he's really
made the rounds take you all right now
yeah
yeah yeah I would've worse I mean I
guess they're tastier when you play with
the circus why did she stay why did she
stay yeah oh I'm used to their format
more of when they're doing like a bunch
of flake they're basically doing like
the all the different throughout the
movie points of no return where you
could have ended differently or
something but this was yeah mainly just
the premise since I mean it's so true
especially with the fact that Mike was
the only one who seemed to truly
remember everything yeah cuz he never
left he never left he could have really
helped speed up the progress yeah and
the finale and then like guys I'm sure
mer we did last time we just got to do
that again
yeah maybe we should give the town a
heads up - what you got to do in case
this guy comes back I am NOT on board
for that ending of Pennywise shrinking
down because I just start bullying him
there's a weird writing metaphorical
thing that I can see how that's like
impactful and the meaning of it is more
powerful than the actual plot point it's
just in the amount of time Pennywise has
been around no one's insulted the guy
was belittled no one's been like hey cut
it out okay no I just thought it was
really lackluster and I was half
checking out her in that moment - like I
did I didn't fully believe what was
going on because my brain was going this
can't be the way it concludes right yeah
a little bit and you spend so much time
doing so much other stuff that by the
time we get there I don't know I think I
feel like the movie hurts itself by
spending so much time literally in kid
mode because that keeps what they did
that much more fresh in your mind by the
time they've gotten there again that
whole thing about remembering and the
totems is kind of rendered pointless by
the fact that you spend so much time I
was flashback I thought that was
actually kind of funny to just be like
let's negate the whole thing let's not
bother with the rich
you know because you could have saved
most of it like it really is true you
could have saved most of the movie
especially with the Mike character and
it would have been cool just to see them
adult up you know what they did in the
previous one how they defeated penny was
but this time they really get more
creative so there are there are things
here to what they're saying what the how
it should have ended and actually would
Pennywise defeating them it mean it's
really funny what they chose to do here
but if penny wise actually defeated them
that would have been totally different
than what happens in the story and the
source material different ending as
opposed to the first one to me it's
actually more of a complete two-part
film because in the first one penny wise
loses and then penny wise wins in the
second one and why Oh a leak yeah you
never overcame your fears no guys suck
traumas with you for life and it's only
gonna get worse and all fear will always
overpower you assume you until you're
dead and we should all be like Stanley
afore Lucky Penny wise try and
manipulate them but then he has this
weird opens his mouth and then he
controls them yeah whatever the hell
they call it-- you think their souls are
some boy why didn't he just do that it's
a Bill Hader at one point yeah I don't
know if he can just do it to one person
at a time or whatever but this is
another instance of like okay what are
the rules of Pennywise they have to
scare you in order to eat you or is it
just that he prefers it that way if it
doesn't have to be that way then you're
just like ah penny wise huh this is all
on you man if you failed it's like you
there's no excuses how it should have
ended is so good at deconstructing or
just asking themselves how would a
logical human being actually react to a
lot of the situation's just starting off
with the little girl being like oh my
god what the hell are you you're creepy
you know little kids have fallen for
stuff and kidnappings are real and
whatever but at the same time the freaky
horror movie clown man yeah come on
don't don't go that your parents must
have raised you a little bit smarter
that's the other thing about clowns and
movies is either everyone's afraid of
them and hates them or children are just
like randomly very open even Jessica
yeah good point yeah or even Jessica
Chastain this little ending moment they
had yeah you know what you piece it
together it looks like anyway oh my god
I'm trappin need to get out of here yeah
this is horror movies reliant there's a
lot of the time being stilted in their
fear and order good yeah the sequins
play out yeah well I mean I mean every
movie of the horror variety is up to
this debate but you know people behave
in silly ways when in intense moments
and then it's up to us to go which of
these silly ways is plausible and hey so
yeah the losers need to figure out how
to defeat Pennywise once and for all
right oh is that gonna be hard for them
to do actually it's gonna be super easy
barely an inconvenience oh really super
easy barely a man can beat him he's made
it around to film theories a part of the
film theater video from there to part a
pitch meeting video now they're shouting
him out here I was gonna say is he a
voice somewhere in here is there like it
Ryan George got a straight gotta be
something right that we totally misses
is he in the cast list here no I think
they were just acknowledging the
audience just showing that's all they
were doing that awesome this was great
subscribe to how it should have been if
you haven't done so already you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell also I like
to give a shout out to a man named
Taylor Bentley sincerely want to mention
to you buddy I know life has had its ups
and downs with you as of late I'm one of
those people who's kind of speaking of
Pennywise this sort of segues into
something a little serious in my life
every emotion and every action we take
eventually comes down to love and fear
with everything you got going on in your
personal life at the moment do your best
to hone as much as possible all the
things that do generate that feeling of
self love and love that you can give to
others one thing a day I guarantee you
mad mad mad mad masturbating please I
guess demonetized family-friendly poster
brooder no family friendly way to say
this joke no do one thing nice for
yourself eats appropriate
and gore but if anything sexual we're
screwed
yeah we don't want to teach kids that
example stop I'm sorry being I didn't
Taylor I'm really sorry for ruining the
shot I'm so sorry man you tried too hard
I love you Taylor